foreign
on this Sunday night Russian
Insurrection The Fallout from that
unprecedented challenge to President
Putin's regime for Putin right now it's
a matter of trying to calm the situation
and what it could mean for Ukraine
dodging death yeah it's crazy what
stopped this father and son from
boarding that doomed submersible
hitting the brakes well I was shocked
Global News investigates the delayed
delivery of millions of dollars worth of
armored vehicles plus pride and joy
Canada's lgbtq2 plus Community takes to
the streets
with support from some four-legged
threats
global national with Fara Nasser
reporting tonight Jeff Semple what a
difference a day can make this was the
view from Moscow this afternoon crowds
out and about enjoying a sunny Sunday
but a cloud of uncertainty hangs over
Russia tonight just 24 hours after an
army of heavily armed mercenaries
Advanced toward the capital threatening
President Vladimir Putin's iron grip on
power
good evening and thank you for joining
us that short-lived Russian Rebellion
appears to be over at least for now
after the leader of the Wagner group
agreed to move himself and his troops to
neighboring Belarus in exchange the
Russian charges against them were
dropped but there remained significant
questions about what that extraordinary
incursion could mean for Putin and his
war in Ukraine Redmond Shannon has our
top story tonight
Russian police back in control of rostov
online the only signs left of Saturday's
Rebellion are tank tracks in its streets
this man says everyone is glad the one
day takeover by private Wagner troops
ended peacefully but says it was a sign
of deeper issues in Russia
some rostov residents cheered the troops
as they stood down and lauded their
leader yevgeni pregosian as he left for
Exile in Belarus part of the deal
brokered by Belarusian President
Alexander lokeshenka the failures
of Russia's war in Ukraine are
reverberating increasingly within Russia
itself progression's sudden decision to
call off his Rebellion may have come
after he realized his March toward
Moscow would fail and neither he nor
Putin had much to gain from seeing
Russians kill Russians I think for Putin
right now it's a matter of trying to
calm the situation it won't have been
easy for Putin to let pragosian go free
Putin may have instead calculated that
Wagner's ongoing missions on behalf of
Russia needed to be managed so foreign
Africa and Syria will need a leader and
and the problem would be to find a
credible leader somebody to replace
precaution the chaos sparked by
pregosian could present Ukraine with
Battlefield opportunities and potential
challenges too Tiffy has gone to Belarus
and has kept an effective fighting force
around him then he then presents a
threat again to who's the Ukrainian
flank closest to Keith if this
unprecedented challenge to Putin has
weakened his authority his next move
will likely aim to reverse that
perception particularly among the
Russian public Redmond Shannon Global
News London
Canada and its allies are watching the
situation in Russia closely as are the
millions of ukrainians enduring Vladimir
Putin's war on their country well today
prime minister Justin Trudeau spoke with
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielenski
about that short-lived Insurrection the
crisis exposed significant cracks in
Russia's leadership but as Heather
York's West explains the International
Community is treading carefully in its
response
members of Calgary's Ukrainian Community
together in a show of support anxiously
waiting to see how such a Brazen
challenge of the Russian president will
impact their Homeland we want our
country back we want it to be free we
wanted to be liberated a day after an
11th Hour Deal saw yevgeni pragosian
abort his Mutiny attempt prime minister
Justin Trudeau spoke with the Ukrainian
president on Twitter Vladimir zielinski
said he spoke about the current
situation on the battlefield and shared
Ukraine's assessment of the attempted
coup in Russia there are lots of
unanswered questions including the
questions of what happens to pagosian's
forces do they remain in uh in Ukraine I
mean we saw the extraordinary image of
these forces coming out of Ukraine and
going into Russia yeah just yesterday
Landing in Iceland Sunday Trudeau is
scheduled to meet with Nordic leaders
for a two-day Summit the best course of
action I think is to to wait and see
really we don't want to play favorites
the you know in any kind of conflict
between Putin pregosian or any other
kind of Russian warlord uh you know
there are no good guys in this situation
well the uprising appeared to take
Moscow by surprise reports suggest U.S
intelligence officials had been aware of
pagosian's plans to challenge the
Russian leadership for some time and
this really is fundamentally an internal
matter for the Russians we're seeing it
uh we're seeing it unfold again we saw
the rising tensions over over a couple
over several months that led to this but
exactly where this goes
um we don't know millions of ukrainians
forced from their homes by War will be
watching closely to find out
[Music]
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
and as Heather mentioned Russia will be
top of mind for prime minister Justin
Trudeau when he meets with leaders of
Nordic nations in Iceland this week but
that's not the only issue on their
agenda tariya isri is traveling with the
prime minister
prime minister Justin Trudeau was
invited as a special guest of the Nordic
Summit a gathering of Nordic Nations
which is being held on Westman Island
known for its sweeping Landscapes and
volcanoes and in this small country of
just under 400 000 people the rising
threat of Russia hits especially close
to home Trudeau was holding bilateral
meetings with the leaders of Iceland
Finland and Denmark we'll talk about our
strength on Ukraine we'll talk about how
we're watching carefully the situation
in in Russia right now as as it's been
complex over the past couple of days I
just over the past hour have spoken with
president zielinski and President Biden
the Nordic Summit is largely seen as a
preview to next month's NATO meeting
Finland recently joined and Sweden is
pushing to become a member
protecting Arctic sovereignty and
reducing energy dependence on Russia are
expected to dominate discussions as
Nordic countries increasingly distance
themselves from Russia Iceland announced
it's closing its Embassy in Moscow later
this summer teria israelit global news
near Westman Islands Iceland the U.S
Coast Guard announced plans to
investigate the cause of that
catastrophic implosion of the Titans
submersible last week that killed all
five people on board the Coast Guard has
opened what it calls a Marine Board
investigation with the goal of
preventing another tragedy
the MBI is currently
in its initial evidence collection phase
including debris Salvage operations at
the incident site
an Evidence collection in coordination
with Canadian authorities in the port of
St John's Newfoundland
the debris site is on the seabed less
than 500 meters from the bow of the
Titanic wreck and four kilometers below
the surface a final report will be
presented to help improve International
safety standards for submersibles
meanwhile a family from Las Vegas is now
sharing their harrowing story of how
close they came to being on board the
Titan Mike Armstrong joins us from St
John's with the details Mike well Jeff
as we know there was a father and son on
the Titan last week in fact the dive
took place on Father's Day well as it
turns out those two passengers appear to
have bought their tickets on the
Expedition later than the others their
spots were for a Time reserved for
another family every time I see that
picture of that father and son
uh but for the grace of God it could
have been a picture of us G Bloom and
his son Sean say they backed out of the
Expedition on the Titan last minute well
it's a multi-year project been talking
to Ocean Gate CEO Stockton rush for a
year about the trip Sean bloom had
always been fascinated by the Titanic
and says he was excited at first when he
started talking to Stockton and told me
and my friend about it obviously I was
super interested in the beginning but
then I started um doing a little bit of
research
Bloom says he wasn't convinced the Titan
was safe it wasn't a state-of-the-art
research vessel but a craft put together
with off-the-shelf parts that would be
taken to one of the most hostile
environments on the planet you know I I
asked him if he could ask Stockton to
address some of my safety concerns and
Stockton called me and my friend the
misinformed
the blooms are sharing some of their
texts with Rush in this one Jay Bloom
explained his son was concerned about
the danger Rush offered to talk to his
son by video call in another Rush
offered to Discount the trip 150
000 per person instead of 250 000
claiming it would be a last minute
special the blooms backed out telling
rush they had a scheduling issue the
spots ended up being taken by Pakistani
billionaire shazada dawood and his son
Suleiman I like the similarities between
us and them and inside it's kind of
jarring thinking about how that
literally were one move away from that
being us this is really focused on one
thing and that's the pressure vessel Jay
Bloom says he met with Rush in person
March 1st at a Titanic exhibition in Las
Vegas he says Rush argued the dive would
be safer than flying in a helicopter or
scuba diving he says Rush pitched him
hard but appeared to have complete
confidence in the Titan Jeff wow close
call Mike Armstrong St John's thanks
Mike
smoggy Skies coming up the Canadian City
ranked worst in the world for air
quality
foreign
Montreal isn't breathing easy tonight
and it's easy to see why the city has
the world's worst air quality according
to IQ air that's a Swiss tech company
all that smoke from dozens of raging
wildfires in Quebec has prompted smog
warnings for many parts of the province
including Montreal Quebec City and Laval
the summer is just underway but this is
already Quebec's worst Wildfire season
on record
candidates are now in the final hours of
campaigning to become the next mayor of
Toronto there will be a record 102 names
on the ballot tomorrow but just one
candidate has held a commanding lead in
the polls for weeks now former NDP MP
Olivia Chao is widely considered the
front-runner though the race appears to
be tightening in the final stretch our
Farah Nasser spoke with Chao about the
top issues facing Canada's largest city
thank you anything
thank you
after spending nearly a decade out of
politics Olivia Chao now has hours to go
in a race that will change Canada's
biggest city let's start off by talking
about something that that affects
communities all over Canada Toronto is
the epicenter of housing affordability
issues yes it is what are you going to
do in this city that can be an example
to the rest of the country more than
half of the people in Toronto are
renters right and they are feeling
really insecure right now because the
rent is so high I'm trying to do is as a
mayor will buy the building
well if the tenants wants right to
actually co-owned it and manage it so
it's a Cooperative or a land trust big
promises but critics have taken aim at
who will pay some people say that you're
idealistic I mean how are you going to
get the money for this how is this is
this proven is it be done elsewhere oh
yes
it's been done before so money where do
we find the money
so the federal government has a national
housing plan there's like 80 billion
dollars in it across the country and
they have three programs that actually
fits perfectly as the front-runner ciao
is being attacked from all sides
including from Toronto's former deputy
mayor Anna bilau who is responsible for
the city's housing file and has been
endorsed by several former mayors
including John Tory the plan is to fix
services and to build housing and to
make life easier and more affordable not
like Olivia Chow who only talks about
increasing taxes Olivia ciao well she's
the worst of them all Toronto's former
police chief Mark Saunders has been
endorsed by Premier Doug Ford she's fine
with a housing crisis in fact she thinks
you should pay more if you own a home I
want to play this clip okay tell me what
you think of this I'll tell you if you
want my opinion uh if Olivia Chow gets
in the unmitigated disaster
Jeff Ford is uh the premier it's
entitled to his opinion so you think you
can work with him you think yeah I can
I've worked with
John bear Jason Kenny the kennedy pool
is crowded with several high-profile
candidates on the center and right she
will probably be the mayor with the
lowest level of popular support that
we've we've had since amalgamation but
there is no organization on the other
side of this campaign there's no
consensus as to who the alternative
candidate should be you ran in 2014 you
lost to John Tory
um what do you think is different about
Olivia Chao of 2023
and more confident
tell me more
um I I'm not worried about my English
anymore because it used to be like I've
been elected for 30 years Ciao's
confidence boosted by Advanced polls but
on voting day as she's learned before
anything can happen
pharah Nasser Global News Toronto
[Music]
delayed delivery what happened to
Canada's special order of armored
vehicles a global news exclusive next
[Music]
welcome back Global News has learned new
details about the delayed delivery of
millions of dollars worth of armored
vehicles they're used to Shield
diplomatic staff who represent Canada in
some of the most dangerous places on
Earth
Ottawa blames the holdup on the pandemic
but government documents tell a
different story involving an alleged
breach of United Nations sanctions
tariya isri Has This Global News
exclusive
from bullets
kidnappings
one of these vehicles may have saved the
life of Canada's former ambassador to
Haiti it was a political confrontation
and the true the true rocks and the car
Stone on the car not being in an armored
vehicle I could I could have been
severally injured in 2018 Global Affairs
Canada awarded a contract to U.S based
jangle Tactical Systems shelling out
almost 20 million dollars for a new
Fleet of 76 armored vehicles but
government documents obtained by global
news show the delivery was late and did
not go as planned a delay that may have
put Canadian embassy staff at risk
armored vehicle in many countries are
essential to pre to preserve the life of
people because you never know what's
going to happen Global News has learned
dozens of them were stuck in a storage
facility in Jordan because a
subcontractor refused to release them
well I was shocked procurement experts
say Canada had little leverage to get
the vehicles since it already paid 90
percent up front you want to save the
money for when in fact you get the final
product and provide incentives for them
to deliver on time Canada signed the
deal with jankel who then subcontracted
storage to a Jordanian company called
Jordan light vehicle manufacturing or
jlvm
according to government memos their
relationship went South on April 27 2022
jankel informed the government that they
would be severing ties with their
subcontractor due to jlvm's possible
breach of U.N sanctions
un observers claim they documented
Vehicles manufactured by jlvm's parent
company in use by the Libyan National
Army allegedly in violation of a United
Nations arms embargo jlvm's parent
company would not answer when Global
News asked whether it breached U.N
sanctions and it would not comment on
the alleged seizure but in a statement
said there's no current partnership
between jlvm and jankel that's in
contrast to jankel which told us it has
a good working relationship with jlvm
but declined our interview request for
what it calls confidentiality reasons a
government spokesperson blamed the delay
on the pandemic but refused to comment
on the possible breakdown in the
relationship between jankel and its
subcontractor or the alleged violation
of U.N sanctions after our repeated
questions Global News has learned the
armored vehicles were finally released
to Global Affairs roughly a year after
they were seized if you're messing
around and
misapplying a contract of 20 million
what about all the others so I think
it's not just this one it's the
implications that there are others that
are also being bungled the same way and
if multi-million dollar contracts are
bungled procurement experts warn
Canadian embassy staff and Canadian
taxpayers are the ones on the losing end
Taria is rate Global News Ottawa
still ahead beaming with pride why this
Year's parade included heightened
security
[Music]
from a very young age I knew I was very
different the body I was born in does
not match who I identify as
a moment of Pride for this Nova Scotia
Community College valedictorian
eighteen-year-old Quinn Legg came out as
trans to his entire class during his
speech at their graduation ceremony Legg
transitioned at 14 but mostly kept it a
secret the aspiring mechanic says he
doesn't see enough trans representation
in Blue Collar trade so he's now hoping
to change that
I'm so proud to be graduating alongside
some of the brightest people that I have
ever met and I look forward to seeing
the amazing things that you guys will do
thank you
[Applause]
and there was lots of love in Toronto
today as thousands took part in the
city's Annual Pride Parade but the
celebration comes in the face of a
troubling trend of open hostility
against the lgbtq2 plus Community Lexi
Benedict reports
[Applause]
the energy is just
[Music]
and I love it
a celebration of love inclusivity and
the most welcoming environment here
there everywhere is this year's theme
with a focus on proclaiming and
celebrating the lgbtq2 plus Community
this parade is going to be going down in
history in Toronto as one of the largest
Prides that Toronto has ever seen you
can see the excitement and energy
amongst the crowd for today's Pride
Parade best of colors beautiful costumes
cheers and chants to close off a month
of awareness and celebration everyone
just says they're happy to be here we
are feeling the freedom we're just
having the time to be ourselves an
expected 2.4 million people filling the
streets including 40 000 people in the
parade sending a strong message of
respect and inclusivity because for so
long you get picked on you'd get judged
you'd get bullied and it's just nice
that everyone regardless of who they are
are here together this year safety is
top of mind with an increased security
presence amid the surge of threats
targeting Pride festivals and
initiatives across the country we've
asked all of our community members to
look out for each other and we're going
to continue to do this but they say it's
made their Community stronger than ever
it's really important to be out here
other people that they can be visible to
and after wrapping up today's events
preparations for next year's Pride
festivities will begin Lexi Benedict
Global News
and celebrating Pride isn't just for
humans residents of the Toronto Zoo are
also getting in on the fun
[Music]
donning Pride themed outfits with
rainbow colored toys and treats that is
global national for this Sunday night
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]